let's go with this again actually
English I think this is something I
could definitely use some more practice
in and I think it's actually something
that would fit well with my playing
style okay so so far English
symmetrical variation and that is being
maintained I'm gonna try to sneak this
move in soon a 3d form will be prevented
with a 5 I believe a 5 is best here ok
it's being played so now what is night
here an idea no well maybe it is with
like f4 and then to d5 where I'm
controlling it but my other thought is
to go here II won c2 in III this is
assuming that this pawn is gonna play
here though I don't know if it's gonna
play there though let me do this in the
meantime I like reserving my e pawns
possibilities and I think playing here
right now Knight takes pawn takes and
then I could get in b4 I'm gonna go with
this doubled pawns in the center I'm not
necessarily a liability
this one right here on d5 could turn out
to be cramping and some in some way it
does make my bishop look a bit silly
it's not gonna be seeing the B 7 C 6 or
8 squares anytime soon
and now that
okay I'm gonna take and then what maybe
I shouldn't have taken though now this
should be alright I think ooh wait a
second is the Queen close to being
trapped or what Oh Bishop g5 Queen here
the Queen is running out of room anybody
else see that when it was played she
only has one square available to her one
of my students a while ago had asked me
how do you know when you can trap the
Queen or something like that and not
sure the exact response I gave but
something along the lines of whenever
she's really short on squares and right
now she's short on squares so that's
what I'm looking into I see Bishop g5
I'm seeing Queen f5 is the only response
it's a very forcing moves right here as
a follow-up I believe I could play h6
and or h3 threatening g4 and the queen
is dead so I think after Bishop g5 Queen
f5 h3 this move is needed and when this
move is played I can then say to myself
aha d5 is weakened and I could maybe
look to get one of my pieces here I
think it's worthwhile to do that to get
some weakness in the center the Queen
will be saved but this Square will be
weakened I believe this is forced or
actually I guess this pawn push could be
played but it's not without compromising
the kingside structure okay now it's
just the the center that has been
weakened so mission accomplished with
the bishop let me come back to where I
might actually want to run all the way
home
or do I
right here I could get this move in I
don't know if I want to give up my dark
skirt bishop or maybe I do
what about pawn push actually no this no
I'm and I'm stuck I'm gonna play here
and then look to play here next and then
Knight to d2 something like that is my
plan so I don't know if it was worth the
time invested to go forward with that
but at least you could follow my train
of thought and how you could maybe force
a weakness in your opponent's position
because how it plays out in in chess is
what what what actually goes on when
you're just starting out your opponent
will be in the early goings you'll see
some flat-out blunders your opponent
dropping upon or a piece and it may
still happen today in your own games but
then that next level is going to be well
your opponent starts to not drop the
pawns or the pieces and they might leave
some weaknesses but even an even
stronger opponent won't be even creating
weaknesses on their own and you'll be
having to induce weaknesses which is
something that was just accomplished but
then again I still am questioning was it
worthwhile to run in for that was it
time well-spent
not so sure I could gained more time I'm
looking to pivot on e4 and then maybe we
get this in like let me do this right
now my knight wants to be on that
weakened square it's taking forever for
him to get to that point but hopefully
once there it's going to be inconvenient
for my opponent so there is this move
and my position is getting broken down
quite a bit
and I think that that is actually a good
move F form hopefully I can be defending
though hopefully so 95 be for I finally
want to get this move in I have this
square available on b6
I'm with in checking distance with my
knight once it's on d5 I really don't
have another move that I'm considering
besides Knight d5 and b4 pawn takes I
just recapture right away I do have this
defended by my bishop he's a very
important piece to hang on to I think
I'd be welcome to many exchanges here
because I'm finding my king right now as
less safe than my opponents King pawn
takes pawn takes I'm okay with these
exchanges I think it's better for black
to whoa to not do that I don't know
about that move I guess it is allowing
the knight to camp out here for a moment
but are or that's happening okay I'm
gonna take that and then open up the B
file so I guess Bishop takes is what my
opponent thought I had to do but I don't
have to do that let's open this up it's
the B file that I want to be getting to
actually I could get here this pawn
I might end up giving this pawn up let's
play here
rook right here or maybe yeah that's a
decent this could be doubled the F file
it could be a lot of pressure let me put
pressure on this pawn there is no rook
move there more pressure
maybe there's a pawn push at some point
similar to the game against William B
where I have this battery over here and
I eventually played f4 that could come
up as well that might actually be a
pretty good idea
we're evening out with the clocks ah
in-betweener
but I could defend my bishop okay this
is not working out now if there was pon
takes being on my queen I could have
played here and defended my bishop I
think pawn takes on this square would
have been more interesting though cuz it
was on my Queen and Bishop pawn push
pawn push exchange bishops and this
guy's I mean this guy's passed I have
actually I could do this right now I
have enough coverage for it it's trade
bishops and I'm on this point
Queen trade and I'm still on the B pond
so I gave that pond up my rooks are very
active and now this is gonna be leading
to mate I think one Pig looking for
another this is a maintenance repair
and less than 20 now okay ten seconds
remaining okay
good game let's back up here and let's
see how we can make an improvement for
either one of us now okay so you saw my
reasoning with why I wanted to go with
the bishop move I think just play it
safe and by play it safe I think just
capture with the bishop here you don't
run into this nonsense about me being
able to induce some weakness against or
in the center or on your Kings side but
I get one of the two right now after age
three you'd have to do H five Ori five
age five weakens the Kings side ie five
allows me to get to this square it took
forever before I got there but keep that
in mind I'm able to induce a weakness in
right here don't push that pun here's a
better plan maybe you could run with how
about what like what else can you do
here maybe get developed
I wonder if or maybe get rid of your
Knights
my knight somehow queendom queendom
maybe get your Bishop to e6 or here's
another one bit since you're moving this
position instead of that consider
actually b5 what about b5 right here
that's a good way to get your rook
working b5 and this file can open up
maybe your Bishop could play here but
now he's good right here sitting on his
home Square it might be the case here's
one way to view it it might turn out to
be the case that if you play b5 and I
play b3 we have an exchange on the C
file these rooks come off the board and
then it's kind of like this Bishop has
already developed there's no need to
move him in order for him to be playing
a constructive role in the position it
could turn out that you need to move
your bishop in order for the rook to
come over here if the B file is
opening up but I think b5 exchange these
guys come off the board and maybe
there's some way to exploit my king
position maybe can you get your Queen
over here somehow
or maybe play h5h for I don't think the
pawn push is good
I don't think capturing is good I think
keeping the tension is good but maybe
throw another pond into the mix h 5 h 4
induce some weaknesses maybe allow for
your King to come over here is some
slight improvements you could be running
with I think I'm just starting to
definitely be better here that's a upon
his upon his upon there's much less
worry against my king once you're
playing f3 there so